Jason hare he is the director of ESPN's
the last dance
a six-time Emmy award-winning director
and producer of his 10 part documentary
series the last dance well this kind of
snuck up on me I didn't know that there
was going to be a documentary on the
Chicago Bulls Jason how did you keep it
a secret you know we've been speaking in
code for the last years and and just
this week people seem to have gotten the
message okay when did this concept take
place in the offseason after the Bulls
won their fifth title in seven years in
the summer of 1997 a guy named Andy
Thompson who has been a producer with
NBA entertainment for decades and he's a
great guy he's Klay Thompson's Uncle
Michael Thompson's brother he knew
Michael and the Bulls and he saw the
writing on the wall Jerry Krause said to
Phil Jackson you can go 82 and oh and
you're not coming back to coach this
team next year and Michael Jordan had
been very publicly adamant that he
wasn't going to play for anybody but
Phil Jackson so the writing was on the
wall that this was going to be the last
season that this core was going to be
together so Andy Thompson went to his
van boss Adam Silver who was the
president of MB entertainment at the
time and said we should follow this team
around we should embed a crew just
because this is going to be historic and
we need this footage for posterity they
both thought that was a great idea and
they went to Michael unfilled but they
said yes and the footage has not seen
the light of day for 22 years but you'll
see it on Sunday night that's great
am I in the documentary your voice is
yes your voice and your face are um at
various times telling the story of
Michael you know there's ample footage
that we were allowed from ESPN and from
the NBA everybody kind of opened their
vault here so you have a presence Nariko
solutely residuals I'm guessing who do I
talk to about that
you certainly don't talk to the people
who are paying me because I'm well then
I'm not getting any if he has fans not
paying you I your first meeting with
Jordan described it I got a call at 6:30
on a Wednesday night from SD Portnoy who
is his longtime manager and I have been
working with SD and Curtis Pope who is
his business partner for the better part
of a year preparing for you know just
the creative elements and the
storytelling structure that this series
was going to entail and I hadn't met
Michael yet I've never been in the same
room as Michael Jordan at that point
despite 20 years in the business I just
never crossed paths with him
he was from a different generation than
the one that I worked in so she said
Michael would like to have a drink and
they were at a hotel in midtown
Manhattan I was a lot more than a half
hour away but managed to move heaven and
earth to get up there in time to sit
down with him and meet him for the first
time how cooperative was he for wanting
to do this he was well one of the first
questions I asked him is why now why do
you want to do this and he said I don't
and I said why not and he said because
when you see some of this footage it's
so raw that I don't know that people
will be able to understand without
context why I was acting the way I acted
why I had to be that intense in practice
why I had to make every practice more
difficult in any game that the Bulls
could possibly experience against the
indiana's and the Miami's and the New
York's of the eastern conference back in
those days I think when people see just
a clip of me getting on a teammate or
riding Scottie Burrell or yelling at Ron
Harper or Steve Kerr they're not going
to understand that and I'm a little bit
hesitant about that so I said you the
benefit of 10 hours to tell this story
and we have the benefit of time and
resources and context and we'll be able
to sit down and you can explain to me
exactly what you just explained to me
and give that context to explain to
people why you had to do this and we'll
also interview the teammates that were
on the other end of that behavior and
get their perspective on it so I think
once he was comfortable that we were
going to tell an honest responsible
comprehend
Noorie and that's you know good bad and
the ugly warts and all he was all in and
he was adamant from that first day and
and you know to two nights ago when he's
still watching rough cuts we're not done
with this series yet but everybody is in
quarantine so even Michael Jordan is
watching rough cuts of the Bulls Michael
Jordan documentary and he was adamant up
until two nights ago that we include
certain things that I thought well he
may not want this in there he might not
want this in there he wants this to be
as honest and truthful a telling you
this story as possible so it's been a
gift that he's been this cooperative so
you have eight parts done and two that
are still being done we're first and
goal from the one inch line on Episode
six and seven we're in the red zone on
Episode eight nine and and we're moving
the ball down the field we're over
midfield on ten but we'll get there in
time for may 17 I give you a credit
though Jase because I can't imagine if
I'm Jordan why I would want to do this
so I'm not surprised that that was
initial reaction but then you tap into
the competitor who now wants it to be
the greatest documentary of all time I'm
going to guess yeah I think that with
him if it's if it's if it's the team
that he plays on in the NBA being the
best if it's the documentary he
participates in being the best if it's
the breakfast cereal that he's choosing
to eat before he goes out golfing he
wants that to be the best everything
from the time that before this guy
picked up a basketball that was
instilled in him by his parents James
and Delores you do your best at all
times what did he want to talk what did
he love talking about
he liked he lit up he talked about his
family when he talked about his mom in
the first episode we used this technique
where I he doesn't know me so it's
better for him to see these people
saying these things about him and that
goes from Gary Payton and Isiah Thomas
to to his mom so I had his mom read a
letter she's kept all of his letters
home from when he was in college at UNC
and this is a homesick Michael Jordan
writing a letter home to his mom to say
he doesn't have 20 dollars to his name
and he needs money for stamps and she
read that out loud and I showed him an
iPad of her reading the letter out loud
and and he got emotional this is a human
being you know we see this guy as a
two-dimensional figure on our wall he's
a logo on a shoe that's not human but
when you show him his mom reading a
letter home and you remind him of what
he came from and that it wasn't always
this way wasn't always sitting in a
mansion telling stories about his life
that are going to be that are going to
be absorbed all over the world he used
to just be Mike Jordan from Wilmington
North Carolina so reminding him of that
I think that that's a comfortable place
for him to go back to yeah and you do
such a great job getting reactions
that's what I love about your
documentaries and and and so you're
rolling constantly you want to get
Jordans reaction no matter what he's
doing I get that reaction you got that
reaction when he talked about I said
Thomas and it still bothers him how many
years later who's going to be upset with
the way they're portrayed in this
if they're upset they're going to be
upset because they were portrayed
honestly I'll say that but I think that
I don't think anyone was treated
unfairly put it that way
III put my name on the line here to tell
an honest with that said who is it I
there we asked for Isaiah today because
I I know that that is so deep-rooted
with Mike and the Pistons and how they
treated him then lamb beer comes out on
the mother ship a couple of days ago and
says LeBrons the greatest player of all
time
this angle they're taking this to their
their graves how they feel about one
another they really are yeah I think
that there's a mutual respect there and
they'll acknowledge one another but it's
deep man this is this is not the Banana
Boat MBA
this is rough-and-tumble eighties
nineties MBA how much pressure do you
feel none I felt pressure at the outset
to get this thing done but but we're
almost at the finish line and at this
point I just feel pride I feel pride in
the job that my team has done under
these circumstances especially to get
this thing out and we all feel pride
that we can give people a little bit of
an escape a little bit of a diversion
and what's some surreal times here
there's business there's nothing that
watch there's nothing to talk about that
connection that sports brings us it's
not there so I think all of us feel an
enormous sense of pride that we can do
something we can't donate blood we can't
go give someone a hug we can't go
deliver someone food you can't touch
each other you can't be around each
other but this is what we can do to
connect with people so we're all really
proud of that Congrats Jason and well
done with the Bears documentary and of
course the Fab five as well we
appreciate your time and we'll be
watching Sunday night on the mothership
at 9:00 Eastern
Thank You Jays thanks a lot guys that's
a Jason here
he's the director of ESPN's the last
dance documentary